hi we're the fab four out of five from
netflix's queer eye
and we're going to share our opinions on
heterosexual culture today with buzzfeed
okay starting off truck nuts and this is
a cancel no one needs
testicles off the side of your car if
they're gonna have
truck nuts they should have vulva as
well so we're gonna cancel them
we're canceling cancel cancel cancel
cargo shots i don't mind a cargo shut up
can't go
i don't mind a cargo long pen if it's
fitted but i hate a cargo shock
what about an oversized short like not
like marshmallows no one needs that many
pockets so no no no
it's a cancel gender reveal party i feel
like it's like not a heterosexual
specific phenomenon because like gays
obviously we can have babies we have
gender reveal parties however
i do feel that this bi-gender thing that
we do these men and this woman who needs
so much pressure you know i don't know
who i am but i do like but i do like
cupcakes
i do love cupcakes because stop it
because like seriously like what about
if your child decides
that they're trans and now you like
every child should have a rainbow cake
cancel fedoras cancel cancel every
cancel cancel the fedora
i cancel the fedora yes i like it fedora
posters that say live laugh love i know
i don't know
i think why not anything that's going to
remind you to do stuff not with that
kind of feels very much we should aspire
for better fonts
i'm keeping it it's very utah and i love
utah i'm so sorry but
it's very very i don't know oh please
fast
police yes what do you think i'm saying
yes to a fleece vest
if it started out right i actually do
quite like it please first
that patagonia one could be cute okay
tan also wears tifa's willingly and is
proud
i live in you that's your reference
point the only person who can pull off a
vest like this is d-ray who like is part
of the black lives matter movement
other than that cancel these two and one
no
body washing shampoo i'm going to say no
why not oh absolutely not
no they have different right hands right
now ever
you can't like body washes are very
abrasive it's like meant to get all like
the dirt and the debris of like the
airports and like the gross things
obviously but
your scalp honey she's a gentle you know
little she's a gentle little ecosystem
and we don't need to be taking all these
very harsh stringent chemicals to our
scalp that's great
cancer cancer pumpkin spice saute i'm so
over this
barf i've never had a latte in my life
and i never want one so cancel it no i
don't
like it i'm not going to pretend to like
it i love tailgate
i love how tails are so fun great way to
like
when i was a trainer we would go you
would go around the tailgate and we
would do like stunts and stuff around
all the cooks
oh board cancel cancel so hot
that's so unflattering they hit a point
at the leg that's going to make you look
just not very good and it's also this
thing like men think like if their
shorts is somehow like shorter that it's
like somehow
making them gay or whatever it's not
getting married at disney world
no stop it you okay wait why are
children getting married at disney world
i don't understand they need to stop
letting kids get married in america yeah
no it's not the commercialization of
like an old dad
can't cancel it it is not cute 10. hold
on couple costumes that's cute
hold on back up couple costumes are cute
i'm very like anti-couple right now and
you know that
okay that's funny but for me i'm not
anti-couple i think this is cute let's
get you i think it's for me right now
because that couple looks terrified and
uncomfortable flip-flop with jeans
no no no no not on a bell bottom like
that
why would you be wearing with jeans
march madness do not
what's mark's madness it's a basketball
look at the ncc double a
um gorgeous basketball tournament every
year i do like the names like the elite
eight the super six
no cancel cancel cancel why these
promoters
and networks make so much money off no
no what are the creators
what are the cheerleaders
everybody making money except for these
young poor college kids
who are working their butts off okay
hold on one second we work
to learn our tumbling passes for so long
so that we can cheer at those games
yes but i'm saying yeah all four of us
do but people are making money so let's
pay the athletes
pay them that's what i'm saying keep it
with a caveat keep it with the caveat
i'm keeping it
wedding hashtag it's absolutely
canceling anyone's gonna
go back and look at your stupid hashtag
no one gives a cancelling it
i'm so glad i'm not having one for my
wedding i say cancelled by thinking i
hate wedding hashtags please don't do a
wedding hashtag
i'm not it's very tacky can you tell me
more about what you thanks for playing
that was the queer i stopped four out of
five plays ten
trends about straight people with
[Music]
buzzfeed
[Music]
you